on vous répond avec notre invité ce soir
Ulrick deot responsable du centre Andy
chien valde Loire pour répondre à cette
question comment devenir famille
d'accueil enichen merci beaucoup d'être
venu en plateau euh Ulrique et merci
parce que saphire est avec nous aussi
vous allez le voir à l'image elle a pris
place elle est plutôt bien installée sur
ce plateau euh Ulric pour démarrer on va
revenir sur la mission de votre centre
et surtout vos besoins parce qu'il y a
des vrais besoins en terme de de famille
d'accueil oui tout à fait alors la déjà
la mission de no nos sentes c'est
l'éducation de chien d'assistance avec
plusieurs spécialités hein donc on a le
chien d'assistance pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite donc chien personnees
en fauteuil la plupart du temps pour
l'aide à l'autonomie on a le chien
d'éveil pour les enfants atteint de
trouble autistique trisomie ou enfant
polyhandicapé le chien pour personne
épileptique également qui va permettre
de détecter les crises en amont et le
chien d'assistance dit d'accompagnement
social remis dans toutes sortes de
structures maison de retraite maison
d'accueil spécialisé quels sont les les
prix requis pour devenir famille
d'accueil alors les prérequis pour les
famille d'accueil c'est euh déjà vouloir
s'investir dans dans l'association parce
que c'est un invest tisement émotionnel
on accueille le chien pendant un an et
demi donc une petite boule de poil de 8
semaines qui sort de l'élevage et on
essaie d'en faire un futur chien
d'assistance le mieux sabilisé le mieux
éduqué possible donc voilà et des
personnes surtout motivées et qui vont
rentrer le midi on veut que nos chiens
du coup a une coupure dans la journée
donc c'est essentiel ne reste pas toute
une journée en solitude et puis aussi
accepter le départ du chien ça aussi ça
fait partie des éléments on peut pas le
garder le chien ça c'est ça c'est on
fait quand même signer un petit contrat
pour ouais donc non oui effectivement
c'est le côté un peu compliqué pendant 1
an et demi on s'est investi
émotionnellement on s euh voilà on a
prééduqué on a on est le chien partout
vu qu'ils sont à ils peuvent aller
partout avec leur CAP et et là c'est le
moment un peu difficile où ils doivent
se séparer effectivement du chien à
l'entrée au centre quel espace on doit
avoir dans chez soi est-ce qu'on
appartement c'est possible par exemple
c'est tout à fait possible appartement
maison de toute façon nous il y a des
prérequis il faut aller promener le
chien et quand on parle de promenade
c'est en liberté dans des parcs forêt ou
champ donc donc même en appartement
c'est possible la présence d'enfant en
basage par exemple est-ce que ça pose un
problème ça pose pas de souci on sait
que des fois enfant et chien ça peut
faire des très belles histoires mais ça
peut être aussi un peu compliqué de
canaliser aussi bien l'enfant que le
chien dans certains moments mais c'est
c'est pas rédbitoire l' là justement en
arrivant j'ai pas voulu caresser sa fir
en me disant faut pas trop les caresser
non plus c char on dit souvent ça est-ce
que c'est vrai ça c'est vrai il faut
alors on peut les caresser quand ils
sont un peu en formation ce qu'on veut
vraiment éviter c'est que le chien soit
trop intéressé par les personnes
extérieur pour qu'après les les les
bénéficiaires soient éventuellement
gênés à devoir gérer leur chien et puis
une dernière question la présence
d'autres animaux sans du foyer est-ce
que c'est problématique ou pas pour non
sans aucun souci il faut vraiment en
fait que nos familles d'accueil notre
panel de famille d'accueil ressemble au
panel de bénéficiaires on va avoir des
bénéficiires qui ont d'autres chiens qui
ont des chats qui ont des poules donc
nos chiens sont habitués à vivre
avec